euforia es el final de seis meses de
estado de alarma
creo que era súper importante que los
jóvenes hemos estado restringidos igual
que todo el mundo pero siento que ahora
era el momento de dejarlos un poco de
libertad y de poder disfrutar un poco
del verano se levanta el toque de queda
las limitaciones de movilidad bares y
restaurantes pueden volver a abrir de
noche pero no en todas las regiones
islas baleares canarias la comunitat
valenciana' o el país vasco mantienen
restricciones entre otras a la movilidad
nocturna sin embargo no está claro el
futuro de estas medidas porque limitan
derechos fundamentales sin el marco de
un régimen de excepción este fue el
motivo por el que el gobierno español se
decantó por decretar el estado de alarma
en octubre de 2020 porque la justicia
tumbó restricciones gubernamentales por
considerar que no estaban basadas en
legislaciones de suficiente rango queda
en consecuencia autorizada la prórroga
del estado de alarma que se publicará en
el boletín oficial del estado
el estado de alarma que cae ahora es el
segundo impuesto en españa' en el
contexto de la pandemia
el primero fue decretado en marzo de
2020 duró hasta junio e implicó uno de
los confinamientos más estrictos de
europa distintos expertos advierten que
un relajamiento extremo puede volver a
colapsar el sistema sanitario ocho
regiones entre ellas madrid y barcelona-
mantienen una incidencia superior a los
200 casos por 100.000 habitantes sin
embargo ya están completamente vacunados
un 13 por ciento de los españoles entre
ellos la población vulnerable una cifra
que el ejecutivo pretende elevar al 70%
para agosto